I things turn out that I think are
really interesting but I don't have
kinda to take them to their natural
boundary and salt so today what I'm
going to be talking about is something
that I don't think I'll ever be able to
write write a paper on even though I
spent quite a bit of time on it yeah
because i figured i would never be a
could be in this state where there's
always a if i was a feeling that if I
worked one more day on this I would I
would I would really find a beautiful
thing and then I I work one more day and
it continues and goes on like this and I
last time I did this my paper turn out
to be 150 pages long so and it took me a
long time so I decided for now I'm just
going to tell other people what what
things I think are interesting and hope
that you can do it so this is being
videotaped in case because in case any
of what I say has some make some sense
now before I forget however what I'm
talking about is it away from our
sponsor if he is related to ryan three
of the art of computer program book that
was published in april well i got my
copy in april this year and and what I'm
talking about actually appears in five
lines of that book you know it here on
page 6 13 these these two lines talk
about about this paper by by Herman in
our roast I don't know how to pronounce
his name is it Ross to roast anyway he
roasts he's a protest that's what I
would have said he's a professor in
Heidelberg and and then then three more
lines got into another answer related to
his paper and and I said I spent three
weeks writing those five lines and and
but but I want to give you the bottom
line of the of what I found out and
today I'm going to tell you the
motivation and they write and some of
the the guts of the detail now I find
out that this book is on sale till the
end of October you have two more days
and here
here's a book to you know shows all
these books you can get for fifty
percent disco and so you know it makes a
wonderful Christmas present etc and I
brought a couple other handouts to it as
I was going through my files on sorting
I noticed that I had two copies of a
patent on on dis merge sorting if
anybody is interested in in a patent
stuff which is which actually seems to
be a fairly fairly neat idea there you
are and then I also have a bunch of
reprints they send me too many about a
topic that I talked about a year or so
ago so so come and get these at the end
of the hour now I want to talk today
about the title is bubble sort at random
and one dimensional particle physics I
understand that there's a conflict right
now there's a physicist in the next room
talking about computer science and here
i am michigan talking about that physics
it so it's a it's an interesting it's an
interesting both bubble sort and and
puck ends one dimensional particle
physics are are interesting and what i
want to show you is that the related
each other let's first talk about
sorting and as far as we love you n
numbers Tom and we're going to choose at
random a subscript k that's between one
and n minus 1 and then we will we will
replace x xk and xk minus 1 by the min
and Max of X Nick so you know I find it
up random place in there you know I I
point my finger and say oh ok these two
are these out of order if so flip them
and and I keep doing this over and over
again and bubble sort is one special way
of flipping them which you can say
always go
try these to the needs of the needs of
me so used to that puts the biggest one
in the last place and then go part way
and then this way and and until you
finally got it sorted it's all sort of
the systematic way of doing it today I'm
talking bubble sort at random where you
don't have a system you just say let's
try these and put them out of order as
soon as the thing is sorted of course
you're done you know more flips are
going to occur but you might want to
know how long it would take you if
you're doing it at random in order in
order to get them that way now a lower
bound on this is pretty easy because I
suppose the numbers that we are given we
r 0 were 100 like that and now so so
nothing going to happen until the first
time I try to swap these guys and then
it will move over to this right right
now how many steps is going to take on
the average before before I we
before I happened it inside it to do
these two what and yeah n minus 1
because they're n minus one possibility
neat is equally likely oh yeah the upper
one errors are okay in statistics but
not in computer science and and
similarly another n minus 1 steps before
we you know nothing at nothing going to
happen to two we haven't hit this one
now and so and so n minus 1 n minus 1 so
so n minus 1 squared steps is it is
necessary just to be sure on the average
of is necessary just to be sure that
we've got the maximum is it in place
much less sorting the whole thing so so
certainly we can't do it in in in less
than that on the other hand there is an
upper bound and an upper bound could be
order of N squared log in
and the argument for that is is that is
following it's known that that if you if
you want there's an interesting sorting
method called the odd-even transposition
sort goes like this consider that just
suppose that the numbers are put on
lines and this is called a sorting
network we start with x1 xn here and
then when I when I when I draw a line I
guess that means to my comparison flip
operation and odd even transposition
sort it turns out we'll sort it if I if
I do n if I do n words of this alternate
this way to this way then if that is it
will in fact get everything in order and
so and so now it it only takes me it
only takes me n log n steps to to make
sure that I have at least these many
comparisons have been assembled there's
a problem called coupon collecting which
says if there's any coupons that you can
have in your breakfast cereal and you
and you by n log n boxes of cereal then
you know not so many bites you have to
buy until you have found all the coupons
if all the coupons are are equally
likely and and it's it's known that if
ali if all the operations are between
adjacent lines then having more than and
then adding any redundant things in here
doesn't hurt so if you have so so i'm
saying that in n log n steps i would be
able to get all in some order all of the
comparisons this one this one this one
this one this one all n minus one of
them but but I'm only carrying that at
least I got think I got four well I got
half of them and and and however much
time it took me to get half of them
uh that'll be enough to and then back
maybe I can do better than n log n in
this case I don't know how did he yeah
well this would give me the upper bound
of it I've n Square log in have to think
of saying that I would get at least this
network however the in fact the true
behavior seems to be is definitely
proportional to N squared I don't know
the exact constant but I can give I can
say that the the actual time in boo crew
is 4n squared plus Big O of n 2 3 halves
login is is is enough if you do this
many random things then I can show that
that you'll you'll have it this for
maybe is too high though now that's
bubble sort the other problem is is a
one dimensional particle and here we
have a interesting problem so I'm going
to forget about this forget about this
here we start out with zeros and 12 and
a whole bunch of ones and then augment
and then all 0 and we imagine that we've
got a line filled with with with these
and if you if you want you can think of
the ones as part as as things that are
you know it's things that have mass and
0 are empty spaces but if you don't want
you don't have to have to think about
that now well in this case we do a
similar operation and that is we choose
a random interest is between places you
know you can choose to someplace ok and
then I'll we look at the two things and
and if it's a one followed by 0 we flip
it to a zero followed by one and so
nothing's going to happen in this
infinite array until until finally this
flip occurs and then and of course it
will be 0 1 now at this point all the
other possible think so ok now let's get
physics into this let's imagine that
between between all these points here
there's a there's a pieces of some
radioactive atom and and it and and it
gives off a gamma ray I told you I was
going to talk physics in fact I'm it
gives off a gamma ray with the
exponential distribution means that it
that it takes in the chance that that
the next time it fires is is going to
occur at time T between time T and T
plus DT is proportional to this
otherwise it's equivalent to saying that
the probability at time T that haven't
fired yet is e to the minus T so that's
on expert so this is the way gamma rays
seem to occur and we assume that they
have that it's an exponential variable
with
with mean one so it so on the average
each one of these will fire once every
every unit of time now but they're
always they're always going you know
there's particles that these gamma rays
can come up anywhere never gamma ray
comes then then it looks and makes this
transition this min max transition and
so if it's a 10 ill switch to a zero on
and the question is what you know what
happens at as time as time grows with
this calm and so on after a few steps
for example we might have 111 and then
you noes 0 1 1 0 0 1 whatever always
infinitely many zeros after point in
implementing ones ah before a point now
we can we can represent this I not only
as a string of zeros and ones but in an
interesting two-dimensional way and that
is for every for every one of these
little places where the gamma rays can
occur we can count up how many zeros
there are to the left and how many and
how many ones the right to the right
there will be a finite number of zeros
that have crossfit from the right Anna
and a certain number of ones in fact
there it will be relatedly at position K
there will be a difference of K between
the number of zeros of ones to the left
and the right so we can we can describe
this by let's let's see suppose this was
with position zero and so I so I can see
that 10 has crossed over at this place
let me write let me write down below how
many zeros have have crossed to the left
so 10 has gone to the left and no zeros
have gone to the left here two three
four four more
five five six six seven eight nine
eventually that gets larger and larger
but stays finite on the other hand are
so this is the number of zeros to the
left Elsa cake the number of ones to the
right I sub K is a 0 here and then
there's one 1 two 2 three or four four
four five six six seven eight and then
it keeps going up so now if you if you
if you subtract L sub K minus is ok you
get K so you know minus nine minus eight
nine seven minus six minus five minus
four minus three minus two minus 10 and
so on this was my zero point actually
now I can i can draw lines from al-qaeda
arcade and so so for example 08 07 06 16
15 14 24 3 4 for 4 for 3 for 2 i'm just
calling off the cartesian coordinates 5
comma 25 comma 1 6 comma 60 70 things so
in general we get a we get a pass a
zigzag path in the in the the right the
first quadrant and and the path is easy
to understand because where we had a one
over there we're taking a step down and
went at you know so we start up
infinitely many downs and then this
means go to the right down down right
right right down down it's the same as
zeros and ones except what ones mean
down and materials mean right so this is
this is an equivalent is an equivalent
representation of this of this linear
string of zeros and ones and and the in
this case the the gamma rays which were
going vertically here now the gamma rays
are going
45 degree angle and what happens when
you change is a 10 to a 01 the thing
moves up this way hanes one so they so
the area underneath this curve is the
total number of swaps that has that have
taken place so again you can think of
this in the term in terms like physics
you start out with this this quadrant
empty quadrant and then whenever one of
these rate raise comes through and it
hits in one of the notches it forces it
up by one so right now there's a
possible track the next possible
transition there's one two three four
five five waves that this transition
could occur okay and and each of these
is equally likely to be the next one
that depending on which which which
gamma ray decides to come out 20 and the
third is the growth process not not no
Rangers like this are called tableaus it
called partitions they occur over and
over again in mathematics so we get a
random shape and and after n steps at
some partition event is some some some
way to make any other thumb of things
and you can also put numbers in here to
show the order in which had occurred for
example I use the digits of pi whenever
I had a choice of three things to do I
would look at the next digit of pi and
it was 0 i would take the first choice
one second choice to the third choice 3
back to the first choice again and so on
so I I use PI to generate a random a
random thing and I made this I made this
shape by which off oh so you see this
one happens to happen to have a whole
bunch of ones and then 0 0 1 1 1 0 0 1
but the first transition was here then
the second transition here then the neck
here then this one fired and this one
fired and so on you are you with me this
we got this rain coming at 45 degree
angle you you know you're different I
guess the rain comes in this direction
yeah that's done but but the energy
pushes the trackway okay now all right
now so what happens after a certain
number of times and rusts beautiful
theorem is that after n steps after em
steps after n steps you have and suppose
you have the shape is N 1 n 2 up to n
sub n where n 1 is the number of boxes
in this bottom rail here and in n 2 and
so on up to n sub mm and and so n 1 is
greater than or equal and 2 greater than
or equal end sub M which is greater than
0 so this these numbers describe the
shape Ross theorem says that
approximately k plus square root of n k
plus 1 is very close to square root of M
for Kate for 0 less than or equal que
les Mike Glenn so if it says that
actually the shape tends to look like a
parabola and so I generated a bunch of
them at random so that you can see what
they're like let's take let's take it
this for example here's an example 10 so
well it's not too convincing this is the
this this theoretical curve here is what
Ross said it should follow but well you
know only 10 steps we we can't to be too
too fussy so I went to a hundred by the
way the program that the program that
generated this is nice short program I
put it on the web if you look on my home
page under downloadable program so you
can get this and get this program and
make your own experiment so here it is
with a hundred boxes and end up the
ideal curve is shown there but the end
the actual thing obtained I in one
to run this weather with a thousand gets
a little closer with 10,000 it's looking
like that I kept going course because
now computers are bigger in fact this
this took honey a small fraction of a
second I mean it's not actually to do I
to do emit what do I need about six six
and bytes of memory is my limiting
factor in this program and program so
here is a hundred thousand and you see
it's beginning to look pretty good for
for Herman roast at the moment and
here's a million okay so so uh now a lot
of people would say that this that this
is proof enough I mean nothing it's got
to be true right because because I you
know isn't that isn't that convincing
that you didn't and well I don't
perceive to subscribe to that philosophy
my opinion now this is on the contrary
you know this um that calls out to be
explained and not to be just as not to
be sent so so what I tried to do was was
explain it but not only to explain what
you know to I mean he proved that his
group was rigorous but what I try to do
is was it was to find out how fast it
converges you know because he only
showed that as time goes to its this
time becomes infinite and you keep keep
rescaling the problem you get down to
the to the graph that looks like square
root of x plus square root of y equals
one which is a which is a parabola of
area 160 in this case M by the way is
approximately square root of 6m you can
work out the area with this so so so in
this case the the number of alpha of
rows in the shape is approximately
square root of six times the number of
boxes
the number of steps you took in this in
this way okay so um now how did so how
did roast do it and what I want to do is
actually is actually try to sharpen his
his proof to say that the after after a
certain after a certain time I would
like to say okay here's his his
theoretical prediction at a particular
time what I would like to do is is is
give a small small blur around that and
say that almost always it's going to be
going to be within this little interval
of the of what r us say Ross said which
was true and I didn't succeed in doing
that I only succeeded in doing the lower
bound I i'll show you a proof that
essentially that we stayed within square
root of T log T of the where we're at
most square root of T law teeth at that
pitch after two units of time we're most
squared of T logs he units below where r
l said said we were in say the upper
mean it's symmetrical so in say the
upper the upper half of this of this
diagram and so it's an open problem i
have i I've convinced myself that his
proof cannot possibly be fixed up to
give a similar upper bound it can only
show that in the limit the thing does go
to zero but gives absolutely no
information about how fast it goes to 0
now
because it uses state it uses of what's
called let me see what is its semi
additive vocals severity functions and
and will sub additive generating
functions and this is specific it gives
an existence proof but not a but not
Browns oh now so now I do want to show
you then how we get the other and then I
want to I'll tie that back into levels
are the hope the whole thing is based on
whole thing is based on a fantastic
observation that I'm not sure how he
knew that it would have it would work
but it does work and he says let's
change the process slightly and and
we'll say that that whichever whichever
run radioactive molecule well I actually
look let's let's see whichever
radioactive molecule is just in front of
the leading one the very first guy the
very first particle from the right that
one doesn't fire as fast as the others
instead of instead of being either the
minus P it's e to the minus VT where v
is some cost of less than one for
example you know be as one half or
something like that so so it says that
it takes it like let's for let's say I
bet a continued use be in the formulas
but I'll say I have so let's imagine
then that it's going to it's going to be
it's going to take twice as long for
this guy to fire as this guy so chances
are two thirds of time the next swap is
going to be going to be here and only
one third of the time will it be here
because this guy is sluggish it's an
exponential deviate with with a slower
rate only one half per second instead of
one per second now how everything else
stays the same
okay now he shows that there's a steady
state for this problem with the amazing
with an amazing property and and so he
finds yet another way to encode a
sequence of zeros and ones and not and
we and we and we don't use the the l's
and ours like ahead here but instead we
use when length encoding which means we
count how many zeros there are between
between ones so in this in this case for
example the number of of zeros after
each one it there's 10 and then there's
well there's 10 then there's no zeros
then there's three then there's then
there's none and there's one and then
all zeros after a while so let me write
again neither 1 103 or 100 this this
sequence which in his paper was called
y1 y2 y3 except he normalized it
differently he added one to ollies but
with that these numbers count the number
of zeros between ones and so in the in
the diagram what he's doing is he's
saying how long are the left hand
motions so I go up one step then there's
one 10030 10000 that's what this is 113
lupine so the run-length encoding is
another way to to represent a path like
this now what he claims is that after
the process gets going for a while these
numbers y1 y2 y3 are independent of each
other and the probability that they have
a particular state is proportional to
be to the minus y1 minus y2 minus y okay
so each each one each of these lies is a
hazard is independent with a geometric
distribution of probability be for
example of B is one-half it's like
flipping a coin to find out how long
you're going to go in until you get
heads have to assign me half the time it
will be 0 one-fourth of time it'll be
it'll be one it'll be one tail before
you get better so number of tails you
get so he's saying that if B is one-half
in this process it turns out that that
this turns out to be a completely
uniformly random sequence but if B is is
two-thirds it turns out that that the
number of zeros are like waiting time
it's going to sort of pile up with with
the with this parameter two-thirds
saying that the chance that you're going
to need more than more than three zeros
is going to be proportional to
two-thirds cubed and more than 50
Cooper's the fish and so on so each time
you have two thirds of a chance of
hitting your 1013 okay so you know it's
2,000 chance of having another zero and
so and so this amazing property has to
be seen to be believed but I'm running
short a time and i'll do it at the end
if we have if we have time but i would
like would like to prove it for you
because but it actually is is
sufficiently tricky that for two hours i
believe that he had made a fundamental
mistake and i had to and i thought i had
to give him the right corners for it and
the reason that now this is only by the
way this is the wise form an infinite
sequence and in order to show that
eventually it approaches a steady state
this is only you only do this for for a
finite probability for a finite
like the first 10 of them you can say
will eventually become you cut become
this way now I did some experiments with
this to to show you what happens so so
now in this case as I if I'm going from
this one to make the next transition I
would say I could do it in a computer
this way I could say I choose one of
these 50 random but if it happens to be
this guy except it only with probability
be otherwise start over again and wait
until you finally you know you're
choosing one of these other guys or you
choose this or choose this one and and
and I and you did accept it so so this
has only probability be over so it's 44
plus B you know so 1 over 4 plus B is
the probability that this one happens in
this one and this one this one this one
is be over for us to make the next stage
okay so we can we can still a computer a
million things then where might wear
your my example here so I tried for
example B equals one-fourth and here's
the there should be a line of slope
one-third here going from like three
fourths to it if this if this is true
then then each of these wise should be
on the average you know we should get a
sort of a straight line because every
time the number of steps we move to the
left is it has an average alpha of
whatever it is be over 1 minus B so if B
is one-fourth that should be one-third
should be the average number of zeros
that I have between between cases and
you know if I'm only moving this guy
forward one for that a time when I get
here obviously the thing is is being
pushed up and going to be skinny like it
like it like it is here of course you
see that up near the top here it does it
does get get about this is for
million guys it's the same thing with
another another seed now if you go to
fifty percent be as a half you get this
kind of a pattern again I up to two
random seeds here and so at the
beginning of the first transitions y1 y2
and wife wife read either the number of
horizontal steps you take here on the
average you know it will be 0 a half the
time one course at a time to 18 at a
time and so on and on the average you go
left one step every time you go up one
and and so you can see that actually it
is following pretty well a slower 4-1 at
the beginning botanic it comes up here I
have no idea what this curve is that's
it one another one to open problems so
what would you what can you expect and
if you if you have a large number of up
cases and Billy with a shape like this I
know according to Rose theorem that for
a while it looks very close to a
straight line I'm not sure what this
asymptote is our home or what's going on
up here so this influence of the of the
slow down effect at the right hand side
it you know it gradually dies out at the
left and I have no idea how to how to
measure that I tried also with since we
thought b equals three fourths just to
hear here we should have a slope of 1
third and and it is one third at the
beginning but you see then it or I'll it
goes it begins to look very much like
the unconstrained case when B equals one
so so I don't know how long this
influence should should be expected to
last and but I do know how to prove this
this theorem that if you if you take a
finite segment and you say let's look at
the first 50 and fix 50 as a definite
number and then let time go to infinity
these 50 will will approach the the
independent random variables with
geometric history
usion that that are stated here now that
is another important thing that he shows
by the in order to in order to make
these theorems is that if you have two
paths one of which is up is totally
above and to the right of the other or
never met they never cross each other
one stays to the right and then you take
any particle transition the bottom one
never never gets ahead of the of the top
one so that so that if you start out
with any two paths and you and you let
the things fire then then the one that
was originally less will always be less
and similarly for any probability
distribution of Patty and similarly even
when you even when you put this this
special condition on a leading guy
because there's nothing to his right you
can do this and you think you so sorry
you know he when he moves to the right
somebody else all of a sudden becomes
effective this monotonicity condition
still stays still stays true so it so
the initial condition is a completely
empty shape and and that is is less than
the shape of this self steady state
distribution so in so we keep on lefty
irradiation goal over and over again
then this shape will never get ahead of
the of that steady state distribution on
the other hand on this picture it looks
like it did get ahead right across top
you got over but that was just because
of the steady state distribution is only
guaranteed to have this property for for
any finite amount of time and I fixed at
a million in all these example okay now
to the let's see how are we doing yeah
okay now I wanted to show you these the
main calculations for
when I did so so I I have besides that
besides Lee the wise i can i can have x
where x 0 is the position of of the
leading one bit and x 1 l-nb x0 minus 1
minus y1 x2 will be x0 minus 2 minus y1
minus y2 in other words the position of
the city this was 0 this will be 1 3 4 5
6 like here would be six would be X 0
and four would be X 1 and 2 1 the 2 of
the X 2 and 1 would be X 3 so in order
to get if I know how many zeros there
are between then I can you know I have
not one more for the ones so so so we
can relate the position of all the ones
if we know the distance between ones and
we know the first one and the position
of the leading one is easy to determine
because the leading one of just at at in
every second it tends to move be steps
to the right and so and so after T
seconds it's gone BTW steps to the right
with the Poisson distribution so the
fill the power the actual probability
that out that an exponential deviate
makes a certain not yet with with with
parameter V makes up makes makes five
steps to the right is e to the minus VT
of times DT to the fifth over 5
factorial and similarly could private
place for anything else that's this is a
probability that that a given number of
steps is taken in the end the so the
generating function x
of Z our hook for the the position of
the leading one ever at time T is going
to equal e to the v t times t minus 1
this is the generating function for the
poisson distribution the coefficient of
Z to the K will be e to the minus bt
times B to the K or K factorial as I
said now um now we have the the
important and easily remember the laws
for getting estimates of tales of
probability distribution have any
generating function I can say that X of
that the probability that X 0 is less
than or equal to VT times one minus
delta which is VT is what we'd expect
that time t and then we subtract
something and say what supports a chance
that it's actually not that that big and
this is always less than or equal to X
to the VT 1 minus delta x the generating
function evaluated at X for any for any
number x between 0 and 1 this is a that
the the the great tale inequality that
has a two-line proof but that's tough so
this would be e to the minus e to the vp
x minus one for all x between 0 and 1
and if you choose x equals choose x
equals 1 minus Delta then to get an
estimate then this turns out to be less
than or equal to e to the minus Delta
square over sorry Delta squared BTW
alpha squared BTW over to
so the probability that this is that X
has it has some given percentage less
than what we thought it would have of
the position of the leading one tends to
to be bounded by this quantity here
similarly we can be patient we we can
use think the tail inequality but which
has a of this simple elementary proof
for the the negative binomial
distribution which is otherwise so the
probability that y 1 plus y que is this
let is greater than or equal in this
case to KP 1 plus epsilon is less than
or equal to e to the minus epsilon
squared K over 6pq where the generating
function here is Q minus YV of the
generating function for t's just for the
sum of the first place why of z is equal
to Q minus P Z raised to the minus K
power this is that another well-known
probability generating function for make
negative binomial distribution this Q
equals F 1 plus P and in this particular
case is equal to 1 over B over 1 minus B
so p is equal to be over 1 minus p and
so so the this is the this is a formula
that we can use to get a bound saying
that the sum of the wise is unlikely to
be very large and both of these are are
fairly easy like this this formula is
exercise 1 point 2 point 10 23 and in
volume 10 hours computer program so and
I don't I think art of I think Ryan one
is only is for ten percent discount what
now no it's 1 plus p this is this is my
mistake no this is my business it here
is 1 plus P so when Z equals 1 you get 1
plus p minus p equal to so so q is 1
plus p in this formula the i mean i like
to use our you'd like to use P as a
negative number if you wanted if you
wanted to be 2b minus minus than okay
but I like to think positive so I so I
did this because otherwise minus signs
all over the places looks like a form is
negative when it's really positive and
vice versa now ok so now here's the the
Quicksilver oh the crooks of the whole
argument and I want to show a theorem
and that is at at time T the probability
that X the sub 80a is going to be a
constant between 0 and 1 and remember X
so X sub K is the case 1 from the right
so it's the position of the case 1 from
the right and that this is greater than
or equal to be t minus 80 over 1 minus B
minus square root of t log team so
probability that is this is is bounded
and actually I'm say it goes to 0 very
fast and so what I what I actually liked
it is is that isn't is abbreviation
called Q s which means quite surely
an AAS means almost surely but Q it
means quite sure enough in probability
theory when you say yes it means that
something happens with probability run
as time gets infinite but when I'm
talking about finite estimates and I say
quite surely I'm saying that this that
actually X the distance condition holds
except with probability that's so small
it goes to zero faster than any
polynomial in T so it's something that
it's not necessarily exponentially small
but it's super polynomial you smell that
in other words this holds with
probability is greater sorry this this
is very small probability it's less than
this with with very high problem so I'm
saying that this is very blowing this
will be less than or equal to something
that you know it's big o of T to the
minus a trillion or something like that
any polynomial here it'll go it will go
to zero faster than that and so I'm
saying that this is that that the
opposite of this statement is quite it
quite surely holds quite surely xat is
is is I'm sorry I did this wrong though
quite surely X of T is bigger than this
so it's very unlikely that it's less
than it okay now here's the and I'm
going to going to write down all these
steps on a blackboard because they're
not too long and because I say this is
my only chance because I'm not going to
write the paper so so here's my proof
and so first of all this is I want to
show that this is probability is small
and so I get an upper bound and the
first thing is I I want to first of all
I have to take this integer part in
order to make sure it's manager X with
atheism agenda fine otherwise and so I
will make the right hand side have the
same integer part in it and but by
increasing the by increasing the this
slightly I make the probability a little
bit worse so so so I raise the right
hand side a little bit so it's still
getting
i'm giving a generous estimate here now
this is equal to the probability at x0
minus sorry x0 minus 80 minus the sum of
the light of y 1 plus y 80 that's it
that's that's my formula for x xk that I
head up there x2 is equal to x x0 minus
this that expands this is less than or
equal to the right hand side which like
I'm going to write as 80 times oh sorry
I can leave the right hand side just as
it is actually so I'll just leave the
right hand side just as it is and now
I'll rewrite this again probability that
X 0 is less than or equal to be t minus
square root of T log T over 2 plus the
sum of the wise this chalk is getting
impossible pun- good thanks minus 80 p
plus sorry minus square root of T log T
over 2 i'll get a better person
I guess maybe I should have said I'll
try to do that the pad at the table
their work better okay now what did I do
to get i took this t log T and I broke
it into two parts I have I took half of
it and put it here and half of input in
here this 80 that was on the left I took
tracking it from there and I changed it
to minus a TPP is be over 1 minus B so
so this was a sort of you know simply
this cancel with that and gives you this
which is the which is one of the
expected value of the lies Oh each each
of these lies is expected to be p on the
average and so so here we're sort of
subtracting the average value from those
guys and here's this is the expected
value of x not so that is so that is the
there I'll go to the right and now but
this is near the end this is a less than
or equal to 5 a x 0 is less than or
equal to be t minus RT log T over 2 or y
1 plus y 18 is greater than or equal
it's mean plus squared t log p delta 2
i'm saying that if this holds this has
to hold another way to say it is if this
doesn't hold then this can't be true in
other words if if if x if x 0 is large
and the Y's are small then then you then
you can't have have this so so this is
the word or and there and this is less
than or equal to the probability of the
two events separately it's not less than
or equal that plus Delta Y
greater than are you so now each of
these is going to be true exponentially
with you know super polynomial small
probability because of the tail
inequalities that we that we wrote down
here for example i can send delta equals
so this is BTW x 1 minus delta if i take
delta to be to make this thing work out
so this will be log T over to spirit t.v
and then this BTW 10 1 minus delta will
will equal listing and so the estimate
on the probability of this is going to
be e to the minus delta squared BTW over
2 so this minus delta squared is log t
squared over 4 x's another 2 times 4
times T times B squared times BTW this
is Delta squared b t over 2 so this is 8
here and notice that the bt cancels and
so you get log squared over 8 b + + e to
the log t squared goes to 0 faster than
any polynomial a polynomial would be e
to the constant log x log t in this
argument instead of log t here I could
have any function that grows faster than
square root of log team and similarly
for the wise this one you use the other
tail inequality where I had them to 6pq
and so on and Amanda and again and again
now you find that it's it's log T
squared times something that's
essentially constant so this is for
fixed a and B for any fixed and B's
between 0 and 1 this this theorem says
that this is is you know is less than or
equal to they go of T to the minus
anything okay
and the nice thing about when you have
things that hold quite surely you can
you can you can combine them you know if
you have any any polynomial number of
things that hold quite surely then they
all hold quite surely and so on and now
so this is where I get the quantitative
estimate because the boundary point of
the of the shape at time T is actually
are the form x j + j j so in this in
this picture when I have the y
coordinate equal J the x coordinate is
XJ plus J remember that the difference
between the x and y coordinates was
equal to well I'll is the different
different notation but what this is is
the way it happened so XJ is a position
of the jf one and so when I what I've
now shown is that the probability that X
sub I've shown that X of 80 is greater
than or equal to that is greater than VT
minus 80 / 19 d minus square SI larki
quite surely because the opposite is is
very well and therefore you see this is
up this is greater than almost always to
to this but now I choose be equal one
minus square root of a turns out that
you know fixing a I want to know what
exif of one half t is or 140 or whatever
is what value of V gives the best bound
on this side and the best outcomes when
b is 1 1 minus rue de and so in this
case it turns out that you get 1-2 rue
de plus a tee and 18
so um and this is the PISA points on the
on the curve that that rust said so what
I've got here is a proof that works for
all a bounded away from zero that that
we stay above the predicted curve of
minus a small amount which which is
looking like square root of T lot of
teens milk while the curve itself as I
position T so this is the so this is the
the precise form of a lower bound for us
esta okay I see that time is running
short so I'm not going to go into any
other thing go ahead but I did promise
to tell you about bubble sort again so
we got to see what that means so what
what it means is that if you if you take
if you take the special case be equal
one half a equals 14 and T equals 4 n
plus c x squared n log n for some some
quantity C and you can you plug this in
it turns out that the entire region at
this time the entire region of n by n is
included in the shale almost surely so
let's let's let's see what it means so t
is approximately four end here a is
one-fourth so this says that that I have
a point n here actually a little bit
bigger than n here I have again
one-fourth so gives for poor n this
turns out to be one-fourth and so this
again is one for the 400 approximately n
and so it says that they at this point
on the on the boundary is is is bigger
than any both directions so that this
holes
and by n square is included so so after
4 n steps after time for n I've got I've
got an N by n square enclosed in the
hole in the whole lot shape okay now in
order to care that n by n square I must
have generated a whole bunch of steps
that is that that give me better namely
on the first step let's take n equal
screen a 3 by 3 square in order to have
generated this first I had to generate
this guy and at some point or other had
generate this one in this one which
means that these complete flops did
occur and these three swaps also did
occur I'm going upward instead of
downward in my light diagram of sorting
networking in these two and then n this
one so so you have so these nine these
nine comparators occurred and if you
look at that the bubble sort process it
turns out that the right half of this is
is what bubble sort does on when you're
sorting four elements in sorting four
elements bubble sort makes these these
comparisons and so if I just look at how
many of the so just focus my attention
on on this half of the diagram and I go
up to time T time for in and and i have
n particles that are irradiating uh
saying maybe maybe make a comparator so
i have n n particle to n particles and
anti mm and uh and when t is for n are
almost surely they're making about in
about 4 n gamma rays coming out and so
for n squared is the number of is the
number of comparisons that are being
made here and so I'm guarantee that I
help I will have generated these bubble
sort comparisons as well as probably
some other and that's seen that
completes what I said about
ok now just before coming here I had
another idea and but I got but I didn't
have kind of two work it out but but i
but I I know it's true and that's what
and if I had if I had time I would love
to pursue it further and that is take
any any square like the one I had 0 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 so on any young such square
and and look at the formula for the
probability that this that this tableau
occurs at time T I I showed that if it's
that if it has n boxes in it there's it
there's a formula for it that has only n
plus 1 terms and you know it starts out
with e to the minus the number of
notches in here to you meander and so on
it but you can you can you can generate
if you're interested I can show you
afterwards uh you you can generate the
the formula for for this and then I
think looking at the thing for small T
is going to be interesting look at the
power series and I think guy turns out
to be cn2 the I'm sorry CT two to the
ninth or something like that plus I'm
something no all 0 coefficients up at
the point and then what this coefficient
c is for small t i think is interesting
Ross theorem gives us the value for
large team but throughout the behavior
of these things for small T you know
physics opening points that the Bose
Einstein statistics are interesting at
small small scale one when other
statistics are interesting Alaska well
okay thank you for your patience I'm
going to give another talk I think it's
the first thursday in december every
year i give a talk about trees in
december and and then I'm planning a big
talk in
worried about a new computer that I've
been designing that I'm quite
enthusiastic about okay thanks
yeah please don't